our teams of safety experts scientists
clinicians and epidemiologists
have investigated reviewed and evaluated
thoroughly and scientifically
all safety reports and our safety
reviews are carried out in tandem with
the vaccination program
we've gathered a large amount of data on
the safety profile of the available
vaccines
and we've done a rigorous scientific
review of all the available data
with regards to suspected blood clots
with low
platelet count the commission on human
medicines expert working group
has also met frequently and critically
accessed
all the data alongside our regulatory
review
and this has also included lay
representatives and
advice from leading hematologists
based on the current evidence the
benefits of the covid19 vaccine
astrazeneca against covid19
and its associated risks hospitalization
and death continues to outweigh the
risks
for the vast majority of people
our review has reinforced that the risk
of this rare suspected side effect
remains extremely small by the 31st of
march
over 20 million doses having been given
we have had
79 case reports up to and including that
date 31st of march
all 79 cases occurred after the first
dose
of these 79 cases 19 people
have sadly died these cases occurred in
51 women
and 28 men aged from 18 to 79 years
and from these reports the risk of this
type of rare blood clot is about four
people in a million
who receive the vaccine three out of the
19
were under 30 years 14 of the 19 were of
the
cerebral venous sinus thrombosis with
low platelets
and five were other kinds of thrombosis
in major veins
the balance of benefits and risks is
very favorable for older people
but it is more finely balanced for the
younger people
and we at the mhra are advising that
this evolving evidence
should be taken into account when
considering how the vaccine
is used today we'll be communicating
information
and advice to healthcare professionals
on how to
minimize risks and this will provide a
lot of guidance
including how to report any suspected
cases
the information for healthcare
professionals will be updated
and there will also be information for
the public things to look out for as we
continue to monitor this issue
anyone who has symptoms four days after
vaccination or more should seek
prompt medical advice a new onset of a
severe or persistent headache
or blurred vision shortness of breath
chest pain
leg swelling persistent abdominal pain
or indeed
unusual skin bruising or pinpoint
spots beyond the injection site so
professor simoneau will outline the
commission on human medicines further
advice
but i'd like to reiterate again that
this
is extremely rare